der april steht vor der tür das heißt
wir starten in eine neue aussaat runde
und ich zeige euch jetzt was ihr im haus
vorziehen könnt welche pflanzen ihr
direkt nach draußen ins beet sehen könnt
und welche vorgezogenen oder gekauften
pflänzchen ihr jetzt direkt in den
garten pflanzen könnten
da fangen wir jetzt mit den pflanzen an
die man im haus vorziehen kann ihr könnt
euch also wieder eure haushalt töpfchen
schnappen die mit anzuchterde oder gut
gereift im kompost fühlen und dann jetzt
eine ganze menge klang von außen schaut
weil viele mädchen hier bei der anzucht
liegen wir starten mit dem lauch da ist
meine sorten empfehlung der blau-grüne
winter den könnt ihr dann später im jahr
ernten eine ganz tolle ertragreiche
leckere unkomplizierte sorte also
wirklich eine absolute empfehlung da
sehe ich jetzt immer in einem töpfchen
mehrere samen aus also so ungefähr
naja sagen wir mal 10 bis 12 samen in
einem töpfchen und da können die dann
auch alle zusammen drin bleiben die muss
man also nicht um pflanzen und tieren
bis sie dann nach draußen in speed
wandern wir dann immer auch daran denken
dass man sich schildchen schreibt so
dass man nicht vergisst was man wohl
gesät hat machen wir weiter mit dem
kohlgemüse da kommt jetzt eine ganze
palette angewiesen wie man jetzt im haus
vorziehen kann zb der rosenkohl das ist
jetzt schon ein wintergemüse also denkt
daran jetzt langsam also das ist
wirklich noch früh für rosenkohl im
april aber man kann jetzt auch schon
plätzchen vorziehen wie man dann erst
nächsten winter erntet und das braucht
immer seine vorlaufzeit mich fragen
immer im winter ganz viele leute was
kann ich denn jetzt anbau dass ich im
winter auch aus ernten kann aber die
gemüse die ihr im winter erntet die baut
ihr jetzt langsam richtung sommer an
damit sie dann ernte bereit sind weil
sobald es draußen richtig kalt ist
wachsen die nicht mehr großartig weiter
das heißt sie müssen bevor der herbst
kommt schon richtig volume und massel
angesetzt haben damit ihr die dann im
winter ernten können wir werden jetzt
auf jeden fall in aller erster rosenkohl
sehen ich sehe da ganz gern die sollte
idema das ist unsere lieblingsorte wenn
ihr noch andere sorten empfehlung habe
für mich ergeben wie sie schreibt die
gerne in die kommentare weil da freuen
sich glaube ich immer alle drüber wenn
sie sich da ein bisschen
operation holen können uns ein paar
geheimtipps abgreifen kommen wir vom
rosenkohl zum rotkohl der ich jetzt auch
wieder dran wir sehr gerne die leute
granata nicht sehr die ganzen kohlgemüse
so aus dass alle erstmal in ein
schälchen kommen und dann täglich die
späte sobald sie ihre ersten laubblätter
nachdem kein blättern gebildet haben
also erstes richtiges platte haben
dürfen sie dann in eigene tapian
umziehen
hier kommt mal ein gemüse das ich neu
ausprobieren dass es eine kreuzung aus
wirsing und weißkohl ich weiß gar nicht
so ganz genau wie das ding heißt ihr
steht viola geo di verona sicher vor
falsch ausgesprochen aber auf jeden fall
werden wir das mal ausprobieren das
zeigt sieht super schön aus ich bin
immer für spitze zu haben
wie könnte man das nennen und kreuzungen
aus wir sehen und weißkohl und mirko
lila hat also nur beim futter gemüse das
wird ja wahrscheinlich eher ein kandidat
sein der auch ein bisschen frost hat ist
halt jetzt mal lesen machen wir weiter
mit dem brokkoli cafés auch immer wieder
vorgekommen das ist so eine sache
die wieder anfänger gärtner oder garten
anfänger falsch machen nämlich dass man
einmal zum beispiel im februar oder märz
die ganzen gemüse aussieht und danach
überhaupt nicht mehr und dann erntet man
halt auch nur einmal im sommer unmengen
gemüse und danach ist alles aufgegessen
wenn man muss wieder einen laden gehen
und da das ganze gemüse einkaufen dass
man vorher schon überhaupt nicht mehr
sehen konnte weil es einem zu den ohren
raus gekommen ist deswegen praktizieren
wir die gestaffelte aussaat und
gestaffelte ernte so dass wir immer
wieder kleinere mengen von jedem gemüse
vorziehen oder von fast allen genießen
bei manchen bietet sich das nicht so an
wie bei anderen aber fast alle gemüse
sehen wir immer wieder
jeden monat oder alle paar wochen am
laufenden band aus so dass wir immer
wieder wurde rat in mengen giganten
können es macht einfach dann irgendwann
auch keinen spaß mehr wenn man einfach
keine zucchini mehr sehen kann
deswegen immer wieder am laufenden band
auswählen schaut rein wir machen jeden
monat ein video zu den gemüsen die
gerade dran sind und dann macht immer
mit und sieht einfach eine kleine menge
von jedem gemüse aus so dass ihre am
laufenden band mit versorgt seit
ansonsten könnt ihr euch auch gerne
meinen aussaat kalender herunterladen
der ist komplett kostenlos da habe ich
einfach für jedes gemüse die perfekten
auszeit punkte rein geschrieben so dass
ihr keine aussagen mehr verpasst da
steht auch drin wenn man die sätze die
man vorgezogen hat dann ins freiland
raus pflanzen kann
wie kann ich euch gerne mal da oben
verlinkten und ich packe euch auch ein
link unten in die video beschreibung
solltet ihr ihn euch einfach
herunterladen und ausdrucken können und
man kann ihn auch auf dem handy
abspeichern und so weiter das ist denke
ich ziemlich praktisch wir machen mit
dem populi weiter der kommt auch in sein
eigenes schälchen und später pikieren
wie die dann so dass jedes pflänzchen
ein eigenes köpfchen hat soll sie dann
nach draußen wandern als nächstes kommt
der kohlrabi da werde ich jetzt nichts
von aussehen weil die essen überhaupt
nicht gerne kohlrabi auch wenn für jedes
jahr welchen anderen aus welchem grund
auch immer
da kann ich euch aber trotzdem zwei
sorten empfehlen die wir ganz gut finden
einmal die sorte super schmelz und man
die sorte als tourist da als los da ist
ein lilafarbener kohlrabi der auch
ziemlich cool aussieht ich glaube
deswegen sehe ich die liga wieder
man muss nichts anbauen was man nicht
ist machen wir stattdessen lieber weiter
mit dem blumenkohl von dem können wir
nämlich gar nicht genug bekommen
der bekommt jetzt hier auch sein eigenes
zuhause und da sehe ich jetzt die sorte
erfurter zwerg aus wir haben ja in den
letzten aus videos in meine frühere
sorte genommen und jetzt langsam kann
man auch gerne etwas mehr alle
ressourcen verwenden
dann kommt ein weißkohl den wird so
sauerkraut herstellung anbauen da kommt
jetzt ein großer satz von mir weil ich
davon ziemlich viel ernten möchte wer
wieviel sauerkraut essen da waren wir
richtig er die sollte domäne
das ist eine sorte die sich super zur
sauerkraut herstellung eignet aber man
kann sauerkraut auch aus allen anderen
weiß konsorten herstellen nur manche
sind eben ein bisschen weicher ein
bisschen wässriger als andere
man kann seiner frau auch wunderbares
rotkraut herstellen das haben wir auch
schon mal in der macht eine ente haltbar
challenge gemacht und ich weiß dass es
ganz viele von euch das auch super
lecker fanden also ich find oft das gut
zu sauerkraut sogar noch leckerer als
das normale jetzt kommen die licht
kaymer die salate da sehe ich jetzt ganz
viele unterschiedliche sorten aus weil
jetzt kann man so ziemlich jede sorte
anbauen und später im jahr 80 dann
darauf dass die shops fenster sind aber
jetzt ist es noch nicht so bald sommer
soll es wieder die volle auswahl haben
startet mit einem eis salat die sorte
heißt mythos und da muss man darauf
achten dass man die samen nur oben auf
die erde drauf streut und dann an drückt
weil das wie gesagt nicht einmal sind
die nicht mit erde bedeckt werden wollen
oder höchsten so 12 millimeter dick ich
habe die erde jetzt schon vorher in
allen töpfchen angefeuchtet so dass die
schon mal feucht ist aber wir werden sie
gleich auch noch schöne der brause hier
an gießen so dass alle samen auch gut
eingestellt werden so dass sie auch gut
kundenkontakt haben die recht praktisch
die habe ich mir gerade neu zugelegt und
damit kann man echt schön finde ich voll
cool
wir machen weiter mit einem
eichblattsalat die sorte habe ich noch
nie angebaut ist wegen verrat ich die
ihr euch jetzt auch nicht das kann ich
euch noch nicht guten gewissens
empfehlen war wie gesagt wenn ihr
irgendwelche sorten empfehlung hat
schreibt sie in die kommentare ich bin
auf jeden fall immer total heiß drauf
und ich liebe es neue sorten
auszuprobieren und auf herz und nieren
zu testen
wir wollen auch irgendwann also diesen
wirklich noch zukunftsmusik was kann ich
echt aussehende aber unsere
kursteilnehmer beten uns immer dass wir
saatgut kistchen verkaufen die zu den
pflanz pläne passen die wir in den
kursen haben und deswegen probiere ich
auch schon super viel zahlt sich aus
einfach damit ich euch noch eine größere
bandbreite an sollten empfehlen kann und
irgendwann wird es kommen sicher nicht
dieses jahr ende nächsten jahres planen
das schreibt mir mal was ihr davon
haltet wenn wir so gut verkaufen wilden
wilden wir auch alles daran setzen diese
bakterien und sortiment aufzunehmen
wir sind sogar schon mit einer züchterin
im gespräch die jetzt auch mal in unser
team kommt ob sie den auf ihrem hof
anbauen könnte das wäre fast beim salat
schreibe ich mir die sorten nicht dazu
weil die kann man so gut
auseinanderhalten das brauche ich dann
könnt ihr das dass ihr mehrere tütchen
saatgut von einem derselben sorte hat
und trotzdem beide aufreißen ist oder
wenn ich so mies dass auf jeden fall
sollten empfehlungen die ich richtig
guten gewissens gehen kann
die sollte little gem ist ein richtig
schöner fester kleiner salat der super
lecker und knackig ist und er kann alles
richtig richtig tolle sollte dann sind
jetzt auch die tomaten fällig aber nur
für diejenigen von euch die ihre tomaten
doch nicht vorgezogen haben weil
eigentlich ist für die tomaten 1 sucht
jetzt langsam schon ein bisschen stellt
also anfang bis mitte april kann man es
auf jeden fall noch machen aber wenn ihr
noch keine pflänzchen vorgezogen habt
und trotzdem noch gerne tomaten anbauen
möchte dann macht das jetzt auf jeden
fall weil sonst ist es wirklich zu
später zum april so letzte chance für
euch wenn jetzt noch nicht gemacht habt
halt in die video beschreibung da packe
ich euch den link zum anzucht video wo
ich euch genau zeigen wir die tomaten
sofort sieht dass sich die schön
kräftige pflanzen am ende bekommt ich
mach das jetzt nicht weil unsere tomaten
sind schon in der erde aber nicht
vergessen
ihr wollt doch nicht ohne tomaten seien
dieses jahr was ist ein garten ohne
tomaten und dann habe ich hier noch eine
komplette gemüse familie die auch jetzt
in die erde wandern möchte
das sind einmal die millionen also zum
beispiel die wassermelonen da bauen wir
gerne des wortes sugar baby an die
kennen bestimmt ganz viele von euch dann
die kürbisse auch ab mitte april kürbis
im haus vorziehen ganz wichtig nicht
vergessen die zucchini
die sind auch ab mitte april fertig
gebacken
dazu kommt nächste woche ein video wo
ich euch zeige wie ihr die vorsieht dass
das machen will nächste woche zusammen
es ist anfang april noch ein bisschen
früh dafür aber mitte april ist wichtig
perfekter zeitpunkt um mit der aussaat
von gurken
anzufangen das ganze kann man auch auf
die anderen kandidaten übertragen also
ihr könnt dann auch gleichzeitig eine
zucchini und eure kürbisse aussehen also
gerne mal den kanal abonnieren wer es
noch nicht gemacht hat so dass ihr das
mitbekommt wenn das video online geht
und auch immer die glocke drücken das
ist zumindest die wahrscheinlichkeit
höher dass man eine benachrichtigung
bekommt den videos beim gehen also das
reine abonnieren das hat teilweise gar
keine auswirkung mehr ob ihr die videos
dann sieht oder nicht leider
also ließen wir unsere ganzen fans ihn
jetzt noch mal schön an und das macht
echt spaß mit dem teil voll cool und
dann machen wir im garten weiter und
schauen uns an dass wir jetzt aus
pflanzen und daraus wählen können und da
fangen wir mal an mit der dicken bohnen
einem werk coolsten gemüse wie ich finde
das super wenig leute an waren die könnt
ihr jetzt auch noch legen das ist so
ziemlich die letzte chance also viel
später würde ich sie nicht sehen
wir sehen unsere auch ganz gerne im
september die sorten teams blende ich
euch auch wieder hier unten ein da könnt
ihr die sorte hängen da und grünkern ich
anbauen sehr leckeren ertragreiche dicke
bohne ich habe jetzt gerade auch
sauerampfer und blut am sehr gut an fall
ist eigentlich nur der schönere
sauerampfer also der der so ein bisschen
rot geändert ist die hübschere blätter
hat aber ansonsten nehmen die sich nicht
viel
so ein tolles gemüse was mehrjährig ist
was lange im bett stehen bleiben kann
was man im winter ernten kann den habe
ich hier vor unserer gewächshaus gesetz
zwischen die blumen so dass wir da nicht
nur hübsche pflanzen anbauen sondern
auch ein paar die man auch essen kann in
asien salat kann man jetzt auch direkt
ins beet aussehen der erst bei mir jetzt
gerade im frühbeet kasten gewandert aber
den kann man auch ohne probleme einfach
jetzt ins freiland säen
jetzt wäre auch schon eher so ein
späterer außer zeitpunkt im april war
der im sommer irgendwann in die blüte
geht und man will ihn ja vorher auch
noch auf essen können
wir waren die sorte green it snow an
bienen bislang oder ruinen klang green
ich glaube das habe ich mich schon
mehrmals mit fünf york dem kanal aber da
gibt es super viele unterschiedliche
sorten und wir haben auch so einen
tollen sonnig stehen wir ganz gerne
anbauen oder noch ein paar mehr andere
als in salate mit erbsen und
zuckererbsen kann man jetzt auch wieder
sehen die sehe ich auch am laufenden
band also immer wieder kommen neue
ärzten ins beet so dass man immer wieder
laufen frische erbsen ernten kann weil
ich sitze gerade
im video zur rankhilfen erbsen braucht
ja irgendwas das sie unterstützt an dem
sie sich festhalten können die haben wir
diese schön und kringel bedienen sich
festklammern an den zweigen die man in
die erde stecken tipps sind für die
zuckererbsen die ambrosia und für die
mark ärzte die sorte ambassador ja aber
das wird ein ziemlich tolles video und
das auch toll wie man mit so rank
elementen den garten gestalten kann das
macht einfach richtig was her wenn man
sich da ein bisschen diesem monat habe
ich auch mal wieder ein exotisches
gemüse mit reingenommen oder ein
unbekannter riss ging wie es nämlich den
hirschhorn wegerecht das ein sehr
gesunder salat würde ich jetzt mal sagen
also wir essen ihnen auf jeden fall als
salat aber man kann ihn auch dünsten
oder mit in die gemüsepfanne schmeißen
den kann man jetzt auf jeden fall auch
aussehen und auch die route meldung von
der ich euch letztes mal erzählt habe
wie kann man jetzt auch wunderbar
aussehen um einfach mal ein paar andere
gemüse anzubauen die man nirgendwo im
laden bekommt und die auch super lecker
und super gesund sind jetzt ist auch der
erste monat wo man den mangold direkt in
speed sehen kann im trubel kasten habe
ich ihn schon ein bisschen früher
ausgesehen wie das auch völlig in
ordnung so
aber im freiland haben jetzt ab april
mit dem man gott auch richtig loslegen
das ist auch wirklich ein sehr tolles
gemüse was richtig viel ernster r prüft
wo man eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts
falsch machen kann also schnappt euch
eure tütchen und zählt auf jeden fall
mangold aus und am besten wenn ihr es
noch ein bisschen hübsch haben wollt den
mit den bunten spielen also der gelbe
stil hat orange farbene pink weiß und so
weiter dass sie dann noch viel schöner
aus wir kaufen dafür ganz in den sorten
mix rainbow und karotten titel auch
nicht fehlen oder ich würde das so irre
wie tolle karten man in den kompost
bieten anbauen kann im moment ernten wir
vor allem die sorte gonzenheimer treibt
die macht nicht viel her die es nämlich
sehr kurz und sehr klein aber dafür kann
man die auch in den ganz frühen monaten
anbauen so sein bin ich ein ganz guter
kompromiss den man damit eingeht aber
die schöne möhre die kommt jetzt dass es
die sorte milan die macht so richtig
schön lange wunderschöne tolle kräftige
karotten und ich freue mich total wenn
die dann ein paar monaten ernte bereits
sind weil klar sind die süß die kleinen
knuddeligen gonsenheimer treiben hören
dass es eben diese frühe sorte aber so
richtig stolz bin ich erst nicht die
sorte milan ihren tipp wenn ihr eine
doppel grabegabel oder auch nicht ganz
normale grabegabel habt dann geht mal
darüber die karotten anschauen wollt
oder auch die pastinaken die
als zweites auf meiner liste stehen dann
geht da hin und lockert die erde richtig
schön tiefgründig auf aber ohne sie zu
wenden und dann seht ihr da ihre
karotten rein und dann werden die
wunderschöne lang und nicht so bei nick
und kurz und schrumpelig wie sie
manchmal werden bei dem passive haben
wir eigentlich zwei lieblingssorten ich
finde ich schwierig da für eine zu
entscheiden das ist einmal die aroma und
dann die sorte halblange weiß die sind
beide wunderbar und nehmen sich echt
nicht wie das man muss auch nicht beide
anbauen weil sie sind sehr ähnlich wie
radieschen kann man jetzt auch direkt
und b10 wie quasi rund ums jahr und das
ja auch eigentlich müsse was richtig
schnell die erste ernte abwirft also
wenn ihr radieschen lügt dann macht das
auf jeden fall wir mögen die gar nicht
so gerne also ich sehe die eigentlich
immer wieder aus kann man auch so gut
die reihen mit markieren wenn man zum
beispiel sony langsamkeit das gemüse so
eine schneise wie die pastinake ausfällt
kann man in der zeit gut zum paradies
zusammen mit rein geben damit die ganz
schnell aufgeben und man dann sieht die
reihe verläuft so dass man dann zum
beispiel unkraut was links und rechts
wächst entfernen kann und nicht aus
versehen die pastinaken weg ihr hättet
dafür sind ja deswegen ganz praktisch
aber ich mag die nicht ich mag die
höchstens fermentiert aber frisch auch
nicht so mein fall ein ähnliches gemüses
der rettich den könnt ihr jetzt auch
wieder aussehen
da kann die leute ostergruß auswählen
wenn ich mich recht erinnere
das wäre auf jeden fall eine schöne
frühzeitig sorte für so früh im jahr und
später im jahr kann man dann andere
sorten aus die rote beete kann man zwar
auch im haus vor ziemlich ja eben schon
es hält habe aber was ich viel
praktischer finde ist sie direkt ins
beet zu sehen weil dann hast du eine
ganze reihe von pflanzen das blockiert
die nicht den platz im regal also die
vorgezogenen roten beeten habe ich in
kuwait kasten gesetzt so dass wenn
richtig schönen frühe ernte haben aber
ich würde niemals rote bete für freiland
für die große haupternte vorziehen weil
da brauchen wir einfach viel zu viel und
klar macht es spaß gemüse vorzuziehen
aber es ist auch viel arbeit und nimmt
viel platz in anspruch deswegen fakt
guten samen alle in euer bett und da
geht das viel schneller und einfacher
und damit könnt jetzt im april auch zum
ersten mal richtig loslegen wieder ein
etwas unbekannteren wie sie über das
sich auf dem kanal glaube ich noch nie
geredet habe ist die stärkere über die
könnt ihr jetzt auch an
also macht dass ihr könnt ihr direkt ins
geschehen ist ein total unterbewertetes
oder unterschätztes gemüse sich der
kritischen fehler in den hintern
gerettet weil sie auch ein
grundnahrungsmittel war früher und ich
finde es ganz spannend damit zu
experimentieren und als rezepte
auszuprobieren also wenn ihr darauf auch
lust hat dann seht doch auch mal ein
versteck suchen und probierten ein
bisschen rum wie man die lecker
zubereitet wenn irgendwelche tipps habt
ich würde mich auf jeden fall fahren wir
die mir mal unten in den kommentaren
verraten was ihr aus den steckrüben
macht jetzt haben wieder ein gemüse bei
dem man eigentlich überhaupt nichts
falsch machen kann das ist der
hochschule wenn du den einmal in deinem
garten hast dann seht er sich immer
wieder aus wenn du den blühen lässt und
bleibt eigentlich für immer genau dann
aber die preise sind vielmehr aus
deswegen sehen wir auch keinen neuen
regularien der kommt jedes jahr wieder
und während in denen eigentlich den
ganzen winter über ich habe nur jetzt
alles abgeschnitten im herbst ein
bisschen überhand genommen aber wenn es
eine idiotin sicheres gegen wieso gibt
eine cola also wirst du echt nicht was
da schief gehen sollte also dass man ab
und zu hat aber meine güte wenn ihm ein
paar kleine löcher in die blätter weißen
nun möglich deswegen nicht weniger
leckerer salat kann man jetzt auch
direkt ins bett denn achtet dabei darauf
dass salat ein licht kaymer ist das
heißt den boden am besten vorher schön
anfeuchten dann die samen drauf
streuseln auf die erde und nur sachte an
drücken so dass sie mit dem boden in
kontakt kommen also dass sie gut feucht
werden durch den boden und damit in
verbindung stehen aber nicht von erde
bedeckt werden oder zugeschaufelt werden
das kommt so oft die frage worden salat
nicht auch gehst jetzt kann dein gewesen
dass ich noch nie angebaut habe weil ich
mich ein bisschen davor drücke weil ich
meinen boden nicht so umgraben möchte
und sorge haben wie ich die dinge in
seinem team schwarzwurzeln
wahrscheinlich machen und sagen wir
bauen die überall ist gar kein problem
aber ich mag es hier auch nicht so gerne
essen ich mag die nicht so gerne zu
bereiten hier im klebrigen schwarzen
zeug und deswegen muss ja auch nicht
alles an bauen wenn man es eh nicht mag
aber ich dachte ich muss mal mit auch
für diejenigen von euch die
schwarzwurzel mögen so dass ihr wisst
dass ihr die jetzt auch direkt ins beet
lernen könnt deckt zb die jetzt
eigentlich irgendwelche aufkreuzen
sollte ist ein riesen schwarzen und fern
und würde mich wahrscheinlich gerade
katzen hätten sie mich
das deck ist lieblingssorte hoffmanns
schwarze heißt aber sie wird das
wahrscheinlich noch revidieren wenn sie
das video spinat es auch ein richtig
typisches frühlingsgemüse dass man jetzt
direkt ins beet sehen kann wir bauen um
die zeit im jahr zwei sorten richtig
gerne an einmal die sorte matador und
einmal die sorte winter riesen die sind
beide super toll verdi nimmt sich die
sorte winter riesen auch manchmal und
soweit es dann ein bisschen wärme ist
gehen wir zu einer chance festeren sorte
über weil es superschwer ist in den
warmen monaten spinal anzubauen
weil er sofort in die blüte schießt
damit hat man nicht viele probleme mit
spinat und vielleicht ist es auch
einfach in ordnung dass man im sommer
mal keinen spinat ist aber ich liebe
spinat lasagne und deswegen probiere ich
immer möglichst das ganze jahr spinat
dazu haben und im sommer bauen wir ganz
gern die sorte karason an weil die sehr
chance festes dafür ist die aber nicht
so frost hat wie die so hatten die wir
im winter an bord oder die wir auch
jetzt aussehen wo eben noch höhere
temperaturen anstehen und zwiebeln kann
man jetzt auch direkt in speziellen
dabei und wir gern die sorte stuttgarter
riesen an einen klassiker die
wahrscheinlich viele von euch kennen ich
finde es aber anfänger freundlicher wenn
man die zwiebeln und speck zwiebeln
anbaut da erntet man meist es ein
bisschen größere und regelmäßigere
zwiebeln also wenn das gerade dein
erstes zweites oder drittes garten ja
ist dann macht system mit speck zwiebeln
ein bisschen leichter aber die kann man
wiederum nicht so lange lagern wenn sie
dann geerntet hat wir fahren so einen
guten mix aus beidem
jetzt kann man aber auch schon jede
menge pflanzen die man im haus
vorgezogen hat nach draußen pflanzen
oder eben pflanzen auf dem wochenmarkt
in der gärtnerei kaufen und die dann ins
bett pflanzen und dann starten wir mal
mit dem blumenkohl den kann man schon
richtig früh im jahr pflanzen also
teilweise auch schon im februar ins
gewächshaus das gar kein problem wäre es
viel frost härter als mein team so
zutraut und den kann man jetzt auch
schon draußen ins freiland pflanzen wenn
man kein freeway kasten oder gewächshaus
hat eine schöne frühe sorte also die
frühe erste ernte abwirft ist die sorte
oder st ansonsten bauen wir auch total
gerne die sorte neckar kleider an und
für den nächsten kandidaten ist es
anfang april auf jeden fall noch zu früh
aber ende april und im mai ist dann die
kartoffel pflanzzeit es gibt ja den
spruch setzte im april wächst
so will setzte mai kommt zugleich
persönlich so ganz hundertprozentig
unterschreiben würde ich das nicht also
bei uns wachsen auch die apres
kartoffeln meistens sehr gut wenn man
ein bisschen aus wetter achtet und so
weiter aber anfang april noch ein
bisschen gedulden
es kommt auf jeden fall das nötig
kartoffelanbau video also kartoffeln
anbauen ohne umgraben wo ich euch zeige
wie man die pflanzen kann niemand ein
neues beet mit kartoffeln anlegen kann
es kommt rechtzeitig online bevor ihr
eure kartoffeln legen willst also warte
noch auf das video und dann machen wir
das zusammen den sellerie kann man jetzt
auch nach draußen pflanzen die nation
anfang des jahres vorgezogen habe werden
die die ganze reihe mit mir
durchgegangen sein und immer ich mir
eure aussagen zusammen gemacht haben
ansonsten könnt ihr jetzt auch sellerie
pflänzchen kaufen und die ins beet
setzen sellerie ist ein toller
mischkultur partner für kohl
das heißt wir pflanzen immer cool und
sellerie in ein beet zusammen mit dem
lauch packen da dann noch ein kultur
schutznetz drüber der sellerie wirkt
auch gegen den kohl weisslingen der ja
gegen pasching zu schaffen macht und
wenn man den und am netz halten dann
noch im netz darüber hat und das gut
beschwert dann hat man eigentlich keine
probleme mit dem kohlweißling weil
selbst wenn sich immer ein kohlweißling
unter das netz verehrt findet er dass da
gar nicht so gemütlich wenn da auch noch
der stinkende sellerie wächst deswegen
ist das eine tolle chance pflanze um dem
etwas empfindlichen kohle ein bisschen
was gutes zu tun den kohlrabi kann man
auch mit unter das netz packen
der wird nämlich auch ganz gerne von
schädlingen befallen
der dritte im bunde neben dem kohl dem
sellerie ist der lauf weil der lauf muss
auch abgedeckt werden weil die laut
fliege ist so fies die bord ein überall
die löcher rein oder die maden drin ist
es wirklich nicht schön wenn man die im
garten hat und mit dem gemüse schutznetz
das kann ich euch auch wieder in die
video beschreibung packenden links sohn
im netz das wirklich hochwertig ist und
vernünftig und auch mehrere jahre hält
bzw bei uns hält es jetzt schon 67 jahre
ohne probleme da also immer auf eine
gute qualität achten wo war ich der
gewinne ebenfalls kann man den lauf so
auch ganz gut schützen deswegen packen
wir diese drei kandidaten immer zusammen
in ein weg das ist eine ganz tolle
mischkultur man kann sich das gärtner
leben so viel leichter machen wenn man
die beete kluge pflanzen darauf achtet
werde neben bmw axe den salat kann man
jetzt auch nach draußen pflanzen also
wenn ihr salat pflänzchen im haus
vorgezogen habe denkt immer daran dass
die pflanzen ab her
darüber habe ich auch schon im garten
arbeiten im märz video gesprochen und
ich glaube auch im märz auf satten video
also schaut nochmal rein wenn ihr euch
nicht so ganz sicher seid wie man
pflänzchen abhärten aber dann könnt ihr
den salat jetzt auch direkt ins freiland
pflanzen das geht mit allen sorten der
so es gibt glaube ich keine leute die so
frostempfindlich ist lassen sie im april
noch nicht pflanzen sollte wir haben ja
eben schon über das aussehen von
zwiebeln gesprochen man kann jetzt aber
auch speck zwiebel nach draußen pflanzen
oder eben die vorgezogene pflanzen die
hier vielleicht im haus vorgezogen hat
nach draußen pflanzen dafür einfach den
pflänzchen vereint sehen die sind ja mit
mehreren in einem töpfchen so dass jede
zwiebel einfach genug platz hat ins beet
pflanzen und es gab auch sehr sehr gut
noch ein bisschen cooler manchmal
leckerer und vor allem ertragreich als
die zwiebel ist die schalotte ich finde
das immer ganz erstaunlich dass man ein
zwiebelchen steckt also schon ziemlich
hin und dann sechs oder sieben erntet
weil die ja so ein ganzes nest an
zwiebeln bilden also probiert hat sein
irgendwann auch mal aus wenn ihr mögt
weil das finde ich noch viel einfacher
als mit den zwiebeln und man kriegt
einfach viel mehr weiß kohlschreiber
sing und rotkohl könnte jetzt auch
nachts raus und 2000 auch wieder unter
das schutznetz zusammen mit dem sellerie
und dem lauf so machen wir es auf jeden
fall dass unsere mieter uns sehr sehr
sehr gut ansonsten kann man jetzt auch
immer noch knoblauch stecken wenn ihr
das noch nicht gemacht habt schaut in
die video beschreibung weil da habe ich
ein video zu gemacht wo ich euch genau
zeige was ihr machen müsst damit die
richtig schön dicke knollen herunter da
gibt es ein paar tricks und kniffe und
dann geht es weiter mit zwei kandidaten
die wenige leute an baumann werde ich
richtig toll sind einmal im schnitt
knoblauch über den hab ich ja letztes
mal auch schon gesprochen das ist ein
schnittlauch der nach knoblauch schmeckt
den man auch im winter ernten kann und
dann den winter hecken zwiebeln die kann
man auch also sind beides mehrjährige
pflanzen so dass man die immer wieder
beenden kann und die winterjacken
zwiebeln kann man auch im winter ernten
berg hat man immer frisches zwiebel grün
ist eine ganz tolle sache
die habe ich auch hier vor ausgewechselt
ausgesät um da mal ein paar essbare
mehrjährige pflanzen zu etablieren die
auf was hermachen im bett und nicht nur
blumen anzubauen zu einem gewächshaus
ich mag blumen aber ich finde es muss
auch immer gehasst haben was man essen
kann wenn ihr wissen wollt was für
aufgaben jetzt im garten
dann stehen also welche aufgaben er im
frühling nicht verpassen sollte damit
ihr am ende auch eine gute ernte
einfahren
dann schalten wir da trieben vorbei da
findet ihr nämlich mein video zu den
garten aufgaben im frühling ansonsten
geht raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner wiesen uns am samstag
wieder biss dann tschüss